foreign
[Music]
the American Psychological Association
to be an authority on very many things
but I do think that the organization's
website provides a simple yet accurate
definition of trauma it says that trauma
is an emotional response to a terrible
event and mentions as examples accidents
natural disasters and rape so if your
house was hit with a tornado while you
were puddled in your basement with your
children or if you were involved in a
high-speed Collision on the highway and
you nearly died or if God forbid you
were sexually abused in the past then
there's there's a good chance that the
experience will have a psychological
emotional impact that will stay with you
for a very long time or possibly forever
and the APA says that a traumatized
person will typically experience shock
and then Denial in the short term and
long term they may find that their
relationships become strained they may
have flashbacks
trouble sleeping you know migraines
insomnia all of these are symptoms of
experiencing that trauma it's a very
it's very real you know uh you can go
through things in life that will have
this kind of effect but the good news is
that for most of us
these sorts of events will be rare light
life is difficult because we are
conscious agents living in a fallen
world full of pain and suffering and
there's a certain amount of existential
anxiety that comes with that and is
always at least bubbling under the
surface of our everyday life
but every day discomfort is not
traumatic or at least it shouldn't be
which means that if you find yourself
frequently describing your everyday
experiences as traumatic
and if you can do an assessment and see
that
things other people cope with relatively
easily are somehow sources of trauma for
you
then that's a good indication that you
are the problem
if you're constantly talking about your
trauma and finding new things to be
traumatized by that means either that
you're being whiny and hysterical
because you want attention
or you really do feel traumatized by
everything which means that you're you
are emotionally fragile to an extreme
degree either way the problem is you
and that sets us up for this story
published on Friday by Rolling Stone
they tweeted the story with this caption
exclusive current and former staffers to
tell Rolling Stone that the Kelly
Clarkson show is toxic behind the scenes
they say Clarkson is fantastic but
allege that they are underpaid verbally
abused traumatized and put in
uncomfortable positions
yes we have yet another tale of a
hostile work environment a story of
trauma and emotional abuse and other
things like that it was only a couple
weeks ago that we heard about the
alleged hostile work environment over on
the now defunct Tucker Carlson show on
Fox News in the past we've heard Tales
of hostile work environments on shows
like Ellen Degeneres and Dr Phil and
others now this could be a sign that
people working in television are slaves
suffering horrific abuses
it could mean that being a 27 year old
PA for Kelly Clarkson is more grueling
and taxing than being a 14 year old in
the coal mines in 1873 it could mean
that
or it could mean that the media business
is fast-paced and high pressure and
results oriented and it attracts a lot
of young adults and this is a bad
combination because many young adults
these days are too weak and too timid
and too incompetent to keep up in that
kind of environment
so it could go either way let's
investigate and find out reading from
Rolling Stone it says quote when the
Kelly Clarkson show debuted on NBC in
the fall of 2019 the talk show
immediately became a beloved fresh
addition to the traditional daytime
lineup with a built-in fan base from
Kelly Clarkson singing career who have
been rooting for her since she uh first
won the American Idol competition 2002
the show captivates audiences over the
past Four Seasons the pop singer has
interviewed guests like Hillary Clinton
and Dolly Parton she's performed Kelly
segments where she sings covers of other
people's popular songs like Whitney
Houston's Queen of the Night and Adele's
Rolling in the Deep and has maintained a
level of Candor relatability with
viewers at home
but behind the scenes employees say they
were overworked underpaid and that work
at that working of the show was
traumatizing to their Mental Health
a former employee ads quote I remember
going up to the roof of the stage to cry
and being like Oh my gosh what am I
doing why am I putting myself through
this
wow I mean what was she put through I
say she because I'm assuming this is a
woman though unfortunately that may not
even be a safe assumption anymore but
what happened what would cause a grown
adult to take time out of her day while
she's still on the clock
to cry like a baby
do they keep her in Chains in the
basement and force her to do her job
while you know against her will while
her manager comes by with a whip and
beats anyone who isn't keeping up
is working the Kelly Clarkson show kind
of like being a galley slave on a Roman
ship in the first century is that how
bad it is
but we'll have to keep reading and find
out former employees say the toxic
Behavior behind the scenes starts with
executive producer Alex Duda who Shields
Clarkson from what staffers say they're
enduring because of the climate Duda
created
I think Alex Duda is a monster former
employee says I have a friend who's an
executive producer who warned me about
taking this job because apparently she
has done this on every show she's worked
on as for Clarkson their current
employees as well as 10 former employees
are under the impression she isn't aware
of how bad things are for lower level
staffers some of whom say they've taken
on other jobs as babysitters dog walkers
and ubereats drivers to pay their bills
now notice how we've made it several
paragraphs into this epic tale of Woe
and we've yet to hear any specific
examples of trauma being inflicted on
the staff the only specific detail we
get
so far is that low-level staffers have
to take on second jobs
my God the humanity you mean to tell me
that when you're just starting out in an
industry and you're a low-level employee
you might not make a lot of money and so
you have to do other things to pay the
bills how terrible
I mean that's only been the experience
of literally millions of people since
jobs have existed
I had to do the same thing when I was in
my early 20s I've worked two jobs at
various points I've worked three jobs
I've had times when I worked multiple
jobs and one of the jobs was an
overnight shift so imagine getting off
of work at like 10 30 p.m instead of
going home to go to bed you have to
start a whole new job at midnight
well many of you can imagine something
like that because you've done something
similar It's Not Unusual it's not
harrowing it's certainly not traumatic
it's just work and you'll be fine
you've seen the CEO of innovation
refunds and getrefunds.com on TV
explaining how they've helped so many
small businesses with their ERC tax
refunds they completed thousands of
returns for different kinds of
businesses Innovation refunds has
hundreds of five-star trust pilot and
Google reviews and is certified with the
Better Business Bureau in around eight
minutes you can easily start the process
on getrefunds.com and you could be on
your way to receiving up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee the ERC
tax credit is a refund of your already
paid taxes it's not a loan it's designed
to let the business owners direct the
refund money into anything the business
needs to grow that's money that you can
use to improve your business however you
see fit but you got to go to
getrefunds.com to start the process
there's no upfront charge they they
don't get paid unless you get paid
Innovation refunds it's already helped
clients claim over five billion dollars
in payroll tax refunds through the ERC
and they may be able to help your
business also go to getrefunds.com or
download the app from the app store
today that's getrefunds.com today
we know when you're out there looking
for a job one of the hardest things to
do is to figure out how to stand out and
stand out in a positive way too because
you can stand out in ways that would not
be so great uh standing out can be tough
especially when you're looking for a job
or when you're hiring looking to find
that application that really stands out
and that's why you need to check out zip
recruiter zip recruiter helps you find
the most qualified people for your roles
fast right now you could try a zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
Walsh simple recruiters matching
technology helps you find the most
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles see a candidate of life you can
easily send them a personal invite so
they're more likely to apply their
user-friendly dashboard board makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place let
ZipRecruiter help you find the best
people for all of your roles four to
five employers employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you could be one of
them you can see for yourself go to
ziprecruiter.com Walsh to try
ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
so where is the real trauma here well
let's keep reading one former employee
says that they recently quit working at
the show because a producer who reports
to Duda yelled and cursed at them
multiple times on stage they say they
develop so much anxiety from the way
they were treated at work that they
would regularly vomit and exhibit
physical signs of sickness
this job deteriorated my mental health
they say the second former employee says
that they took a leave of absence
because their mental health was also
suffering they say they were bullied and
intimidated by producers who went out of
their way to make staffers feel scared
to ask questions and get their work done
according to the staffer this prompted
them to take a month away from the job
and see a psychiatrist for the first
time in their life because they truly
couldn't handle it mentally
the former staffers say they've worked
in the entertainment industry for years
on different sets but the Kelly Clarkson
show is by far the worst experience I've
ever had in my entire life it deterred
me from wanting to work in daytime ever
again they say when I say I was
traumatized I was really traumatized
oh you were really traumatized were you
really really traumatized when other
people talk about traumas they've
suffered in life they're referring to
things like watching a parent uh die of
cancer watching a friend get blown up on
the battlefield and and
you know those are trying experiences
you feel comfortable using that same
language just to describe your
experience of getting yelled at by your
boss
there's no reason to keep reading by the
way this is it this is the only this is
the one single scandalous detail we're
given
some people yell sometimes traumatic
you know I once had a boss years ago
um in a meeting cussed me out at the top
of his lungs and throw a book across the
room in a fit of rage
I wasn't traumatized I didn't lay awake
that night trembling with tears in my
eyes I never sought therapy to help me
recover or cope I think later on I told
one of my co-workers about it and we
laughed because the guy's a psycho and I
think that's the last time I ever
brought it up to anyone until this very
moment
now should your boss scream and use foul
language in the workplace no is it is it
inappropriate yes should it be a crisis
in your life and a source of deep
emotional trauma should you be crying
and vomiting because of it no absolutely
not people lose their tempers sometimes
it happens it'll happen at work
if you're working with other human
beings like yourself if you're working
in a high pressure competitive business
like media it's even more certain to
happen tempers you know emotions run
High sometimes
you don't need to alert the media about
it we already know and we don't care
at the beginning I said that we can
interpret all this whining over
insignificant things as either
disingenuous and performative or a
sincere expression of extreme emotional
fragility but I think the second option
is the more concerning one and
unfortunately I think also the correct
one
we have bred a generation of Americans
to collapse under the slightest pressure
to recoil and heart any amount of
discomfort and difficulty
and at the root of this disease is their
belief that they have the right to a
life free from discomfort and difficulty
they haven't been raised to understand
that hardship is an absolutely
Inseparable part of life of The Human
Experience
they truly believe that a life of total
ease and luxury is available is possible
and anything that interferes with that
pursuit of this fantasy is therefore a
violation of their human rights
people in the past didn't complain
nearly as much about their toil and
suffering even though they experience
both to an infinitely greater degree
than we do
because they recognized that this is the
price of admission for conscious beings
in a physical world
that's why even if you've suffered
actual trauma real Trauma from a truly
traumatic experience it's it's still not
a good idea to harp over it the way
these people harp over every stubbed toe
and paper cuts
you know one of my favorite scenes and
one of my favorite stories ever put the
screen uh the uh the Western miniseries
Lonesome Dove
happens right after Diane Lane's
character as a prostitute named Lori is
kidnapped and then terribly abused by an
outlaw named Blue Duck
Robert Duvall's character uh Gus kind of
this grizzled old western guy rescues
her and later that night when they're
sitting together Lori breaks down in
tears and says uh they shouldn't have
done that to me Gus they shouldn't have
taken me and Gus gives her a hug and
Pats her shoulder and says I know honey
but they did I know they shouldn't have
but they did they did
dumb modern audiences may watch that
scene and interpret it as Gus being
uncaring or dismissive but it was the
opposite his point was that you won't
gain anything by dwelling on the fact
that your past sufferings shouldn't have
happened yes it shouldn't have happened
but it did happen and the point Gus was
making is that you'll never be able to
function in the world and truly heal
unless you accept reality for what it is
it shouldn't have happened but it did
now what
if Gus would say that to a woman who'd
just been kidnapped by Outlaws in the
old west
what would he say to a grown woman
crying on the roof at work because her
boss was kind of mean to her
she shouldn't have yelled at me at the
time he yelled at me for being seven
minutes late to our production meeting
Gus she shouldn't have done that
maybe if he was in a kind mood he would
Pat her Softly on the shoulder and
deliver the same message I know honey
she shouldn't have but she did
but if he did that he'd probably end up
getting fired and then sued for sexual
harassment because he touched her
shoulder and called her honey I think
the better response in the latter case
would be something like yes honey she
yelled at you people yell sometimes
that's life what did you expect did you
expect that nobody would ever lose their
temper at you ever in your life
even when you're doing annoying things
like showing up late to a meeting that
everybody else managed to get there on
time for so you want everyone else to
exercise total and perfect emotional
restraint but you're the one up here on
the roof crying like a toddler in the
middle of the work day
at least the mean people are productive
you're useless look at you
now get back to work or you're fired
that's what I would say anyway
she probably is why I'm not in
management they'll do it for us today uh
have a great day everyone talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed